this month many americans plan to buy
christmas gifts from local businesses
eighty percent of consumers in a new
survey say they're likely to shop small
58 ordered online from a small business
during small business saturday over
thanksgiving weekend etsy the online
platform for entrepreneurs and artisans
reports an 85 increase in sellers since
the pandemic began etsy's trend expert
dana isom johnson is here with some
unique gift ideas for us good morning
good morning good to see you but dana
before you even get started vlad just
made her day because when you sat down
and he said what
he said i love etsy she said that's
music
he just discovered it i just discovered
it my wife introduced me to etsy and all
of a sudden like i'm on there more than
i am on like amazon and some of these
other like you know retail outlets
because you can find anything that
you're looking i'm not trying to make
this an ad for etsy but like i was just
like dana said keep talking
i bought my from native sons in
albuquerque new mexico guitar straps
whoa and i bought myself like five
guitars and you you probably felt better
about supporting that small business i
did i looked at them i looked up who
they were and why they started to make
these like handmade guitar straps um
although my wife is like why do you got
five
i mean that's a different story you need
to switch it up
but this notion of supporting small
businesses how important is that right
now it's so important i mean and there's
a few reasons why the first reason is
because you know exactly where your
dollar is supporting right you know that
business the second is that you have
that opportunity to potentially
personalize because you're working with
a real person behind that company the
third reason is because you can support
exactly the location that you want if
you choose to so you can set those
search filters and say you know i want
to support uh albuquerque new mexico or
i want to support virginia where i'm
from the last reason is look we know the
supply chain issues are happening the
great thing about supporting small
businesses is because they mainly work
with local materials they're not faced
with those same supply chain disruptions
really interesting now you talked about
personalized and i'm looking right next
to you um is that what you would
describe shopping with intention
because that's one of the trends you're
seeing right oh yeah so that's that's
one of the reasons you can you can say
that this is shopping with intention
with personalizing an item right but i
think more so people really want to be
thoughtful with their purchase right so
whether you are personalizing an item or
you're choosing to support the small
business in the first place or you're
wanting to support an underrepresented
community let's say you want to shop for
a black owned business you want to shop
from a latin x own business you can find
that on etsy wow the other thing i like
you know you probably don't know this
but i had a grandchild recently
congratulations
but one of the best gifts kirby got was
from etsy where they have a little
blanket and you can personalize it it
goes 11 months 12 months yeah the little
baby lays there that's what i like about
their personalization isn't that what
etsy is known for the personalization is
a huge business and very popular isn't
it absolutely i mean personalized gift
is actually the top searched item for
the past two years so people know that
they can come to us they can work
directly with that real person and get
it personalized in whatever way you want
so whether that means getting a special
saying on a cutting board or getting
your grandson's name on a blanket it's
really completely up to you and you get
to talk with that real person we keep
hearing about the supply chain
that it's very difficult
to to meet the demand is etsy having
that problem too good question yeah i
mean like i said i think the great thing
is that because so many of the small
businesses are working with local
materials they don't have to wait
exactly the port of los angeles exactly
so really it's small business supporting
other small businesses for materials and
you're just going to feel good about
your purchase i think more than ever
shoppers really want to feel good after
they make that purchase now you didn't
come empty-handed yeah you brought up
your goodies i'm looking at a candle
right here yes
absolutely beautiful and smells
tremendous what else did you bring us
okay well the first thing i want to talk
about the theme from these items here
right one of the top themes for items
this year was all about this norwegian
concept called free let's live
and so it loosely again free free looks
live
yeah and so it's all about enjoying the
outdoors bringing nature inside and then
bringing the comforts of of india inside
outdoors so that candle is a great
representation of that you see those
beautiful botanicals around the candle
details it's so beautiful the other
great thing about that is that votive
just pops right out of the middle so you
never have to lose the beauty of the
candle you just replace the votive wow
what else we got okay so then we've got
this great planter here that i thought
that was a cbs plant me too
i also thought this iphone i was like
this iphone case looks pretty good yeah
you can probably find a great iphone
case but that was ours
but no
this is a cork planter okay and you know
like i was saying another reason people
want to shop is first being more
sustainable yeah that's a great example
also so many people moved and so you
really want to find great hostess gifts
or new home gifts so planters are
awesome or you could do these
personalized cutting boards which are
great you can what is sustaining oh
that's a custom map so this is another
great example that's a map so you can
work directly with this seller and let's
say you and your spouse met somewhere
it's just amazing
how is this a map it's it's all hand cut
so you work with the seller and say
these are you know manhattan oh the
streets
got it yes got it got it got it yeah
okay got it well dana we appreciate you
thank you so much um
i'll take this candle you can tell
on christmastime